so before we talk a little bit more
about the geopolitical uh landscape
which i think is probably the most
fascinating conversation right now
uh you were so early but you also
tried to orange pill a ton of people you
mentioned peter
are there other folks that you went to
that people either don't know about
uh or folks that you had conversations
with um that just
didn't get it still don't get it like
any stories from the very early days
that would surprise people
right you know i as i've said many times
uh
i was really hard trying to get russell
brandt
who's a famous guy in the uk into
bitcoin
uh you know he he was
not really able to get what it was all
about
this was again when it was you know 50
bucks or so
uh i gave him some bitcoin i don't know
what he ever did with it i'm pretty sure
he lost it
i saw him recently on his podcast asking
people to explain to him what bitcoin is
you know
we we had if you look at kaiser report
we had several shows
in his actual flat in london talking
about bitcoin so
he must have amnesia uh my friend alec
baldwin who i knew from new york
university
uh when bitcoin was under 10 bucks uh 20
bucks you know i was
talking to him about it and trying to
get him into it
uh alex jones of course uh when bitcoin
was under five bucks
i offered to give him 10 000 bitcoin to
give to his audience
as to to spread the word because you
know pop back then in
2011 a lot of people were giving away
thousands of coins as a way to
spread the word you know when it was
cheap like that it was easy to do
so he alex jones he rejected the idea
and said no no that's that's that's a
that's some kind of uh
cia coin i don't want it so he rejected
it he rejected that offer
of 10 000 coins um and
the list goes on from from there you
know everyone i met i was trying to
get and get orange peeled as we do and
i guess those are some of the celebrity
instances
how much bitcoin do you think you've
given away over the years i don't know
how much you have but how much do you
think you gave away in the early days
when you were trying to
help people spread the word or drive
adoption it
tens of thousands of bitcoin thousands
thousands i mean when you think back to
that
worth it well
you never you know you never have enough
i mean it's
i you know what can i say it's uh
in some you know the the bitcoin
phenomenon
ultimately you know i like to think
about buckminster fuller you know
buckminster fuller was a visionary
thinker
and he made a decision early on in his
life that he wouldn't do anything in
life that wasn't beneficial for humanity
and he created the geodesic dome he
created the first electric car or one of
the first electric cars and
he thought strategically about humanity
and bitcoin is something that's
pro-humanity is paul tudor jones even
said that
gold is a bet on disaster bitcoin is a
bet
on humanity that it's going to get
better so
i mean this is part of this is being
involved in something that's going to
improve humanity improve um
what our experience as humans you know
on this earth because
bitcoin demonetizes violence
whereas fit fiat money really monetizes
violence you know the
the petro dollar in the whole war
industry and it's all based on fiat
money and money printing and the ponzi
scheme of money printing it's a very
violent area fiat money is is the source
of violence
bitcoin is demonetization of violence so
in that context you're like well you
know i'm doing something i'm part of a
bigger thing
and and with bitcoin everyone who gets
involved to it and
with a big in a big way really learns to
get humble and say you know what this is
bigger than me
and there's something potentially that
could be great for humanity here
people who are narcissistic egomaniacs
have a
big difficulty getting into bitcoin i
think that's
the nasim to love story he's he's
rightfully proud of the work he's done
with his books etc
but he developed this narcissism that
prevented him it prevents him from
seeing the
the humanity of bitcoin and so he's
essentially
committed professional suicide uh with
his antics
of the past few months and we see that
with muriel roubini or paul krugman
they've committed professional suicide
because they're they don't have the
humility
to approach bitcoin on that on that
level so to answer your question
um sure i gave away thousands of coins
but
if it's part of the journey that if it
ends up being
uh beneficial to humanity as a whole
then i think that that's something we
can all be proud of
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it